welcome back to CBS mornings the
shocking attack on Paul Pelosi the
husband of house Speaker Nancy Pelosi
inside their California home comes amid
growing threats and violent rhetoric
against political opponents and public
officials according to the U.S Capitol
Police in 2021 there were more than 9
600 threats against lawmakers that's
more than double the number from 2017
when there were just under four thousand
we're joined Now by Doug High a former
communications director of the
Republican National Committee and our
chief political analyst John Dickerson
good morning fellas how you guys doing
morning all right John let's just cut
right to it how did we get to this point
well we'll be here till dinner if I go
through everything that we get there so
there are broad courses in politics and
then there's what's happening in the two
parties because it's not the same in
both parties but broadly what's
happening in politics is the increase in
apocalyptic thinking which means that if
I lose this fight All Is Lost you have a
situation also where you have a rise in
negative partisanship so the other
person in the other party is not just
wrong they're evil and these are the
structures of politics that have been
exacerbated by the media by the
heightened partisanship the fact we all
live near People Like Us not near people
unlike us so we only hang out with
people who talk like we do
gerrymandering which is exacerbated that
the media which lives off of conflict
fundraising requires lots of conflict
you don't get a fundraising email that
says oh the other side has a point you
get a fundraising email that says the
other side is at the door ready to ruin
your life and all that you believe right
that has amped up the temperature
stoking the Flames if you will stoking
the Flames there's always been political
violence but now what happens is you
have a system that's structurally and
incentivizes more and more heated
rhetoric and then you have the
difference in the two parties while
there have been victims in both parties
targeted Democrats and Republicans
conservatives and liberals the structure
of the Republican Party more recently
with the Advent of Donald Trump has put
a person at the top of the party who has
consistently advocated violence and who
has created a Market within his own
party where it's fun to joke about
violence to play footsie with the forces
of violence and then you have this
situation where you have Republican
lawmakers when they were retiring would
say I don't want to speak out even
though I'm retiring because if I go back
home I'm going to get threats and and
this is is related to Pelosi but also
the most important thing is in January
6th you had a situation where lies from
the president created a violent reaction
by people who thought I can't get what I
want Through The Ballot Box so I'm going
to turn to violence but they continue to
do so Doug and I know you don't speak
for all Republicans but now this feels
different to me does it feel different
to you we've been hearing about violence
it's going to happen it's going to
happen and now it has happened and it
doesn't seem to me that a lot of
Republicans have been full-throated in
their in their condemnation of it when
it was happening no they haven't and
some make light of it and the challenge
I think that we have in politics is it's
bad when it happens to our side it's
okay when it happens but it shouldn't be
a Republican or a Democrat no no
everybody should be and everything every
member every Republican member of
Congress knows Steve scalise and knows
the security detail that was fired upon
that day of the baseball practice and
other members of Congress who who were
shot at but we have very short memories
and when it happens to the other side we
sort of move past it problem for these
members of Congress is every single one
of them is fearful of the threats that
they all get 435 members of Congress 100
Senators every one of them is getting
death threats and really VI not your
garden variety kind of death really vile
things that are coming every day that
are far removed from the tough talk that
we have in our politics and should have
in our politics that's a really
important Point politics has always been
tough but it's often been tough in the
service of an idea now because of this
negative partisanship the idea that the
other person over there is bad no matter
what we're talking about that's what
changes into this new territory from
tough talk to creating a situation where
it's fun to make fun of them it's fun to
talk about violence with them and that
just raises the temperature but does the
negative partisanship happen because it
works that's why candidates do it and if
that's the case how do you ever convince
a candidate not to do a thing that works
how do you lower the temperature yeah
look negative ads have always worked
they're always going to work but there's
a difference between so um you know in
2010 I helped create the fire Pelosi
movement which was very successful
people regret that now I thought
Margaret did a good job in challenging
Emma Yesterday by saying do you have to
use a gun in that act there's I think
there's a difference when you start
using uh things like that right guns and
ads because you know this guy in San
Francisco is you know obviously a
smorgasbord of of nut job right right
the problem is and but here's the bad
news none of these attacks have been
successful but one of of them is going
to be and we've been lucky that Gabby
Giffords is still alive we're lucky that
Steve scalise is still alive Lee zeldin
right somebody's going to be successful
and that's where we get to the point of
real and unraveling in our country
structurally the attacks work and there
is no market for let's not have an
attack you know there used to be a
situation where in politics you would
somebody would rush into the moment and
and show excessive empathy for the
person who was hurt because they thought
this might help me right there's not a
lot of that so we can sit here and ring
our hands how bad this is we all know
it's bad and then nothing changes right
so what do you what do you really
realistically think it takes to change
and what can a person watching this do
in their own life to make that
difference well the people can stop
incentivizing those who play in jokey
and have fun with the idea of violence
call them out on it they can stop
thinking about the other side as as
apocaly apocalyptic threats to the to
the nature of for the Free World we are
complicated people and not the the other
person is not evil and and and they can
call out lawmakers who who who make a
career out of this and say I don't want
any part of that stop stop perpetuating
that divisiveness that is out there
across all of these platforms that we
all use on a daily basis there's already
those conspiracy theories Elon Musk Elon
Musk retweeted a conspiracy theory that
Pelosi and this guy knew each other
absolutely no truth to that whatsoever
by a source that had previously said
Hillary Clinton had died and that's not
a free speech thing that's a human thing
a man is in a hospital with a fractured
skull and you're playing light with
what's happening and as John said we
could talk about all this till dinner
but we are going to do a piece in the
next block about ideas and we want to
get to it these ideas have been I
appreciated both you uh John Dickerson
Doug high so